it just kind of goes to show that it
doesn't matter how pretty things look on
the outside people still struggle
Savannah Chrisley taking aim at
misconceptions about Mom Julie praising
the family's Fierce and loyal matriarch
it's definitely harder on her I think
than it is my dad the comments part of
Savannah's tribute for Mother's Day on
Instagram I think she's trying to Shield
us from a lot of things because that's
my mom that's who she is a solemn
holiday for the Chrisley's coming four
months after Julie and her husband Todd
began their combined 19-year prison
sentence I don't think there's a single
letter that goes by that she does not
say how much she misses my dad in her
post Savannah slams one of the nasty
rumors about her mom and dad and calls
out those who would love nothing more
than to see my family torn apart mine
and judah's life's you know it's fairly
consistent after 25 years of being
married yes Savannah insists my parents
are madly in love and they'll come out
of this trial even stronger with sister
Lindsay adding her two cents couldn't
agree more four months in almost
um and being together almost 30 years
now and not going a day without speaking
to now going on four months is a lot
I've never seen two people my parents be
so steadfast in their faith in the end
the truth will prevail may get harder
before it gets easier but we have faith
alongside Savannah's impassioned caption
a video montage showing off her fam in
better times hope my Tears Don't freak
you out the soundtrack A fitting Choice
it's Casey musgrave's song
[Music]
mothers if Todd and Julie could share a
message with the world what do you think
they'd want them to know I think they'd
want folks to know that they are the
same people they've always been and
they're going to fight to get their name
clear Savannah admits the holiday
especially hits hard this year I hate it
I'm angry I may be 25 but I miss my mama
so bad my heart hurts we made a
commitment that we were not going to
give up Savannah calls her mom
everything I hope to be adding I will
forever fight for you that fights being
waged as Todd and Julie plead their
innocence from behind bars you don't lie
you don't cheat you don't steal
following their convictions for bank
fraud and tax evasion I think they're
optimistic and let me be clear I think
that optimism is well placed this trial
was riddled with heirs and we expect the
appeals court to see that and while
their legal battle continues Savannah
keeps her spirits bright by paying
visits to both parents that's the hard
part of figuring out like all right who
am I going to go see Julie's facility is
in Kentucky meanwhile Todd's serving his
time in Florida mom and dad are 655
miles apart wish we didn't live wish we
didn't live so far from each other any
family who faces a loved one going to
prison it's a very difficult challenge
but they're strong they're faithful and
I think they'll continue in that Way
Forward